[Musique]
si hésitant qu'ils soient les premiers
rayons de soleil ont déjà fait sortir la
mode nouvelle dans la rue cette fois les
genoux vont se montrer partout
ce qui ne sera pas sans quelques risques
car les jupes courtes ne feront pas bon
ménage avec les jarretelles qui menace
de frapper de disgrâce une ligne placée
sous le signe de la jeunesse et de
l'aisance le couturier louis féraud a
lancé pour sa part l'offensive
il a présenté dans ses salons du
faubourg saint-honoré une formule
résolument révolutionnaire débat qui ne
font pas de plis débat qui tiennent tout
seul extensible à l'extrême ils peuvent
être adaptés à la hauteur voulue
permettant aux jupes de s'arrêter à cinq
et même à 15 cm au dessus du genou
[Musique]
cette offensive n'est pas passée
inaperçue des familiers de la rue du
faubourg saint-honoré pour lesquels la
mode nouvelle n'a vraiment plus de
secret pour les esprits inquiets se
rassurent audacieuse la mode 66 sera
évité les écueils né de ses propre
audace
les bons jours peuvent venir
[Musique]